Je sais ce qu'ils disent de
[Musique]
moi à propos des
romantiques désespérés que nous sommes
faibles et que je ne suis pas
faible. J'ai appris à la dure
[Musique]
toutes les histoires d'amour n'ont pas une
fin heureuse, reprenons ça la
semaine prochaine quoi  est-ce que vous faites ici, nous
pensons que vous pourriez être un
accro au sexe, quoi
[Musique]
peut-être trois fois un charme, ce gars n'a aucune
chance, je n'ai pas bien dormi ces
derniers temps, je suppose que je n'ai jamais eu ça moi quand
j'étais avant  je partage une chambre avec ma
sœur, elle dormait si paisiblement
et je restais là, éveillé
[Musique] en
pensant comment quelqu'un peut-il dormir de cette façon
quand ton cœur ne s'endort jamais
Je sais que tu as l'impression que personne ne te comprend, je
ne le fais pas  même comprends-
moi, ce n'est jamais assez pour toi c'est un menteur
Je ne t'ai jamais menti les
critiques constantes elle pense que je suis son employé
[Musique]
être avec toi, c'est comme à la maison avec moi
mais j'ai quitté la maison pour une
raison [Musique] à chaque fois  quelqu'un m'a demandé ce que je
voulais être quand je serai
grand, ma réponse a été
toujours
amoureuse, tu dois respecter l'Ed et le flux de
l'univers, c'est
moi, c'est moi
maintenant.